where's Tony Danza when you need him
Alyssa Milano protesting at the Georgia
Capitol against the state's new abortion
bill the legislation facing liberal
backlash for banning abortions after a
fetal heartbeat is detected which
usually happens at about six weeks
Milano leading a group of over a hundred
celebrities threatening to boycott
filming in this state which could cost
Georgia billions of dollars on Tuesday
Milano delivered a letter signed by her
fellow celebs to the governor's office
and she was confronted by a Republican
state
[Music]
she has created a whole cottage industry
for herself she's the annoying police
Jessie I just want to make some
disclosure here I have a conflict of
interest with this story
Alyssa Milano was my crush when I was
growing up and I loved her own full
house I thought it Samantha was
fantastic role for her I also had a
crush on Lori Loudon so this week's been
really tough for me
with that said yes I had a crush on her
too so it's hard for me to actually
commentate on people that I had a crush
on when I was a six or seven or eight
year old boy but I'm gonna do it anyway
because it's five I I'm not very great
I'm not biased when I say this I think
it's fine what she's doing I think it's
okay to go in and confront politicians
where they work I think that's part of
the democracy and I wish more people did
that which more people did it on the
other side of course but she has every
right to go in there and raise hell I
thought she was kind of rude when she
said don't interrupt me I didn't think
she needed to do that but I'm gonna give
her a pass cuz I like her I don't think
this is gonna go anywhere at all though
and if anything that's just going to get
her more press for her special whatever
she's filming down there let's talk
about the dollars and cents because
celebrities aren't the ones who decide
where productions dig in and where shows
are filmed states like Georgia give
companies like Netflix a lot of money
and a lot of tax breaks in order to come
and shoot there because they help the
local economies so much
well yes however there are some states
who say that it really doesn't pay off
that well and I think that these
legislators would be better off serve
keeping their taxes low making sure that
the government runs very efficiently and
spending all that extra money that they
give to Hollywood on advertising in New
England especially in New York New
Jersey and Connecticut insane wouldn't
you rather be able to keep X amount of
money in your pocket and live your life
the way you want to live it like I think
that's a better way to spend taxpayer
money I agree with you courage people to
come there then you have a tax base and
it's not people so fickle that want to
leave because you're you are your as a
representative
you are voting the way that your
constituents want so how are they going
to vote here and and does celebrity
input have any influence on the metric
as far as this conversation well
obviously celebrity input they can't get
enough of these celebrities I don't know
why Alyssa Milano there's certain people
that everybody can't get enough of I see
her every day her and I don't get it
Pete Davidson why are these people
why is Pete Davidson in the news every
single day I use dating Kate Beckinsale
they have an age gap and she's super
pretty yeah yeah you want to talk about
childhood crushes but I guess I was
partial to Jan Brady okay Jan Brady you
know grows up and she's like you know
hell-bent socialist and she starts
ripping in through everyone's
legislature and then you have to talk
about it you're gonna feel conflicted
well that's your part of the problem
Jesse because you keep cutting her slack
because you want a crush on her when you
watch Sean here what do you want to
roast the woman yeah yeah you do yeah
all right hold my pen I'll let you be
the ultimate referee here well I'm glad
Wilma glad Wilma Flintstone doesn't go
into the Georgia Legislature I wish we
had run the tape in full because what
happens is they're in a cameraman goes
up to the state assemblyman says hey the
Koch brothers who are funding the
anti-abortion ishutin don't live here
either and he doesn't have an answer so
I think you know that that would have
been the whole story is that fact he
gets embarrassed by the reality that
he's has a double standard in terms of
who comes as Jesse was saying to raise
public concerns about a very public and
controversial issues this heartbeat'
abortion bill but you know to me the
real issue here is that she's a
celebrity and she's using her celebrity
to advance her political agenda and
that's a great American tradition I
think people should do it you want to
speak out this is the one
you go down she's not Jackie Robinson
waters for Washington yeah what if
waters went to Washington to the DC City
Council and complained about things sure
they would not let me into the DC Sun
shortly oh yes they were confronted Mary
power wouldn't let me out
you confronted Mary's that I'm glad
you're here yeah wild night